hello everybody my name is markiplier
yes my hair is still beautiful and red
and it will be for some time if you
didn't see the last video than the first
time you're seeing and then anyway we're
gonna find out if this game actually
saved from the last time which I hope it
dad you better happy you [ __ ] if you
didn't I will punch you in the gonads
like I said before I'm very good at
punching gonads wherever they may like
to hide I will bash you down Please
Please Please Please Please Please
Please Please Please Please yeah that's
my messy desktop hey murderers come kill
me okay now we got to be serious and now
we got to be very very careful about
this [ __ ] okay so let me check my notes
again okay so we got three we got read
them three
I got Craig out my audio so I can hear
the slightest easiest busiest things cuz
I'm a paranoid [ __ ] and I ain't
ready to die what time why can't we be
friends people on the internet can be
friends oh das Locker I bet it'd be good
about this okay okay this is easy yeah
that's easy middle mouse speed up I got
it okay I'm way too stressed about that
one oh no not another one going down oh
boy down then left then up yeah oh man
that one was going too quick too I'm not
exactly ready for it
I just have there's so much at stake I
just don't want to lose it actually no I
can't delete notes apparently the
butcher had nothing we'd post zero day
[Music]
all right are we already got from zero
day which is good so hidden questions
there's a bunch of other ones how am I
supposed to know
what did I do
[ __ ] what did I do
I didn't hear anything I wasn't talking
okay I'm gonna get this if I need to
look up a guide I will but for right now
I think I have a basic understanding of
this there's some websites that do not
work at all there's some websites that
only work in the early evening there's
some websites that only work at late
evening I just have to find out what
they are and I think I've been hammering
the ones that obviously aren't so I just
need to find those and also there I was
recalling back and there was like this
slight whooshing noise and maybe that
was something I don't know shut up okay
here we go whoa whoa whoa oh my god oh
oh oh my god oh it's a puzzle okay okay
it's a puzzle
it's a puzzle yeah
[Music]
I did that with my brain oh my god let's
go there
wait what it's the same thing that's
right yes okay I think it says deep web
wiki too which means that it's probably
more websites and you need that that's
why I could only ever find four which
was the problem father Donald definitely
doesn't have it that's okay I've got my
I've got my then I saw a great white
from his presence and on your website
then I saw white throne and him was
found for them and I saw the dead great
okay
father Donald thank you so much but shut
the [ __ ] up I don't need you right now
okay so this is good because I have to
so I'm going to things that I know have
things like did this have a thing okay
so that was just at the bottom of the
page
what the [ __ ] was that I just went I
went to see if it was the same thing
that it was before and it's not which
means I gotta go through the whole
goddamn page unless I don't see there's
two trains of thoughts right now going
through its either random per page but
now that I've found like an entirely
different area I am thinking that maybe
what am I supposed to I'm being hacked
[Music]
dammit I got his cranked up so loud I'm
I'm keen on every noise oh not this Oh
God what is the name of the pastor that
wants to purge Oh Donald
Oh minimum age for a hit wasn't that 18
I don't know how would I know that
I don't know that okay so I have to come
back to that once I know more of the
things things I don't know them how
would I know them know anything so I
need to go the gatekeeper but this is
deep wacky - this is deep wiki one which
means I have a lot of things to do here
so if I go through this find all in wiki
one and then go back to the gatekeeper
the gatekeeper is probably the last one
and you need to find that second wiki
like
[Music]
to be able to get all of the websites
you need bless your soul
whoa oh okay okay we've been very bad
things have not been going good
[Music]
we've got Oh oh my god we've got five
which is more than we've ever had so I
gotta hold onto this tight
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I've never
been there before
[Music]
okay so what I did there was there was a
symbol that appeared right here
I've never seen it before mother
[Music]
okay so the gate to keep the gatekeeper
the gatekeeper has blood blood the
gatekeeper has questions I don't have
the answer to because I've never seen
the website I have to look that up okay
so I got a better guide we're gonna do
this
goddamnit are you kidding me
[Music]
okay oh oh oh my god I thought I thought
those hack uh I thought oh no oh no oh
yes oh I've never been oh happy
something horrible oh my god oh oh my
god oh man you guys do not know how
stressful that was unless you played
this game and then you know exactly
outside while I was Oh God
this is my reward hey friend my window a
whole bunch oh boy you're already Oh No
not buffering come on geez well I'm glad
they censored it with buffering ah this
isn't rewarding at all
I am NOT doing this to you doing this oh
my god you don't know I stopped talking
there I was so paranoid about losing I
just stop [ __ ] talking
I was the sense of paranoia never went
away my god these thumping beats my bros
raise the roof I'm feeling fleek oh my
god I cannot tell you how stressful that
was like I I'm honest when I say I was
stressed the entire time I was playing
there was ever a time when I would be
playing like I did in any other [ __ ]
game where I'm like okay I get it I'm
gonna die oh babe the stakes were so
high the stakes just kept getting raised
the farther along
you went excuse me like it was just
astronomical how much stress was put on
me such that I wanted to win so badly I
didn't want to go through that again
because it took forever if I hadn't
figured out how to get to that goddamn
second page I would have been forever
thinking of the other web page was just
a red herring oh man but I did it I had
to look up a guide for the gatekeeper
because it was it was asking questions
that I didn't know the answers to and I
feel I gotta turn this volume down just
shouting over it oh my god I feel like
this game is meant to be a collaborative
effort like it's supposed to be
something that a lot of people online
and a lot of people who are playing are
all working together at and because one
person going at this would have a very
tough time of knowing everything but the
idea that all these people for over
4,000 people are trying to look in this
red room is kind of reminiscent of
everyone trying to play this actual game
and
in there so you'd you would think that
they'd be working together and you'd
think that they would be talking to each
other and you think that they would be
spreading information about how to get
through this horrible horrible place
they call the deep web but either way
that was amazing
that was stressful but that was amazing
there are some few nitpicky things that
I could say but I won't say you guys
probably already know about it but just
overall this was an amazing experience I
don't need to really reiterate any
negatives about it I had a great time
and I hope you did too so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]